une fois de plus la télévision a joué un
rôle capital dans cette page d'histoire
aujourd'hui en direct pendant plusieurs
heures des millions de roumains ont
assisté aux discussions de l'état major
du soulèvement
c'était dans les studios de la
télévision roumaine à bucarest
récit de cette révolution direct
jean-marc il use tout d'abord un studio
et friqué une atmosphère de réunions
syndicales
une petite foule qui se bousculent
maladroitement autour d'un micro et d'un
drop et pourtant c'est de ce studio de
la télévision roumaine que jailliront
après quarante deux ans de communisme
les premiers mots et les premières
images de liberté écoutez ne dit que la
roumanie socialiste dit la roumanie dans
les rues de bucarest les roumains n'en
croient pas leurs oreilles
la radio officielle vient de tomber et
c'est par la voix de mme hirsch ya
dinescu poète et surtout opposant
célèbre qu'ils apprennent que nicolae
ceauscescu le tir ont détesté vient de
quitter le pouvoir
déjà une source diplomatique occidentale
affirme que l'ancien ministre déchu
cornelio manescu 63 ans aurait pris le
pouvoir à la tête d'un front de salut
national
prat telle confusion sur les écrans de
télévision occidentales le visage de cet
homme acteur célèbre de la télévision
officielle roumaine passera un instant
pour celui du nouveau numéro un
l'information est fausse mais l'émotion
est juste l'acteur né alors même pas sûr
de survivre à son geste de défi aux
autorités
peut-être allez-vous louvain créé dit-il
peut-être allons-nous mourir
peut-être que tout à l'heure c'est même
caméra diffuseront de nouveau vous dise
pour six minutes mais regardez moi je le
suis ni dieu ni diable
je suis un simple roumain demain je vous
êtes jure de me rejoindre ici à la
télévision comment la famille shalit
tiéné vaud et en dépit des vingt morts
de la nuit et des mitrailleuses de la
milice tout l'accent cordes en vue car
est des milliers de roumains répondent à
son appel
premières images de citoyens anonymes de
romain sans leurs chaînes et de prise de
parole libre dès 10 h 10
c'est qu'on est apte à nouakchott soyons
vigilants attention les hommes de la
milice sont encore partout ceausescu a
plus d'un tour dans son sac
soyons prudents nous ne savons pas
toujours où il est naturel mohamed
miftah dinescu héros national
mais le miracle est déjà là dans les
milliers de voix qui n'ont pas oublié le
vieil hymne national roumain
rien n'est vraiment réglé mais qui lui
sait déjà que grâce à une partie de
l'armée favorables aux manifestants les
terribles miliciens de la securitate et
où pour l'instant céder le terrain dans
le centre de la capitale et on chante
malgré les rumeurs d'une contre attaque
des partisans de l'ancien dictateur en
direction des locaux de la télévision
qui continue à parler au pays et au
monde et avec la nuit la liberté
naissante tombe en direct à la
télévision roumaine incroyable au siège
de l'ex comité central dans l'ancien
palais royal ils sont des centaines de
milliers à écouter les proclamations du
nouveau côté salut national ou même
s'adresser à la foule le premier orateur
n'utilise pas le terme tovaritch
camarades mais frappe si fort mes frères
et s'est immédiatement le délire
et cela partout et puis sans transition
arrive au balcon un petit homme qui
annonce qu'il est sorti de prison voilà
une heure à peine c'est dimitri et matt
hill ou diplomates roumains des nations
unies incarcéré pour avoir osé rédiger
un vrai rapport sur les droits de
l'homme en roumanie
il avait disparu depuis tous les
orateurs il va appeler à la prudence au
calme dire non à la vengeance oui à la
modération à la télévision le défilé des
dernières victimes connues de 25 ans de
police politique continue de la romaine
est dehors
l'histoire sanglante de la roumanie est
encore en marche elle n'a fait pour
l'instant qu'un trou dans le drapeau
roumain un drapeau ou les symboles du
pouvoir communiste ont été
systématiquement arrachés